كيف بدات حتى الساعه القراءات داخل
اسرائيل ان كان من ناحيه التصريحات
السياسيه وايضا القراءات التي تطرح على
وسائل الاعلام حول تبعات ما
جرى الترجيحات الامنيه
والسياسيه ايضا سلمى تشير في اسرائيل الى
انه سيكون هناك رد ورد كبير على هذه
العمليه والانظار موجهه بطبيعه الحال الى
الجانب اللبناني الى حزب الله لكن ايضا
هناك تاهب على مستويات اخرى في ان ياتي
الرد ربما من جهات اخرى لذلك راينا بان
اسرائيل اعلنت نوعا من حاله التاهب وان
كانت لا تعلنها بشكل صريح لكن نقل عن
مسؤولين امنيين وسياسيين قولهم لوسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان اسرائيل في حاله تاهب
واستعداد قصوى لاي رد محتمل وانما نف
جاء ذلك ايضا على لسان رئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه السابق ان من نفذ
مثل هذه العمليه الدقيقه لاغتيال الشيخ
الشهيد العاروري فانما كان يتحضر وكان
مستعدا لكل السيناريوهات ولكل الاحتمالات
وانه تجهز ل ليكون مستعدا للرد على مثل
هذه العمليه مباشره بعد هذه العمليه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو عقد
اجتماعا مع رئيسي المساد والشباك ايضا في
ال مقر وزاره الدفاع في تل اميد لتباحث اي
تداعيات هذه العمليه المحتمله وكان من
المتوقع ان ينعقد هذه الليله اجتماع
للمجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر لبحث اليوم
التالي في غزه بعد انتهاء الحرب لكن تم
الاعلان عن الغاء هذا الاجتماع والابقاء
فقط على اجتماع ضيق لمجلس ال الحرب المشكل
من دائره ضيقه جدا رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ورئيس مجلس الحرب وعضو مجلس الحرب
عفوا بين جانس وايزن كوت ورئيس هيئه اركان
الجيش ووزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه في هذا
المجلس لكن تحولت طبعا كل المواضيع التي
كانت متوقعه ان تطرح وان تناقش في هذا
الاجتماع الى موضوع
وتداعيات هذه العمليه
على الجانب الاسرائيلي وحاله التاهب
بطبيعه الحال ونشير ايضا الى ان حاله
التاهب اعلنت من قبل حتى واحده من منظمات
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي في مدينه تل ابيب تم
الدفع بمزيد من اطقها الى هذه المدينه
ومحيطها ما يعرف بتل ابيب الكبرى استعدادا
لامكانيه ان يتم اطلاق صواريخ تطال هذه
المنطقه في وسط اسرائيل سواء كان من
الجانب من غزه او من الجانب اللبناني
وهناك توقعات كما اشرت ان يكون هناك رد قد
يشمل اطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى من قبل حزب
الله اللبناني في اسرائيل بطبيعه الحال
كما هي العاده لم يتم الاعلان عن مسؤوليه
مباشره عن عمليه الاغتيال ولكن يمكن قراءه
ذلك وفهم ذلك بشكل جلي وواضح من تصريحات
كثيره للاعلاميين ومحللين باركوا هذه ال
العمليه وابدوا رضاهم ووصفوها بانها انجاز
كبير للجانب الا الاسرائيلي ومن الواضح
بان اسرائيل منذ السابع من اكتوبر سم وهي
تحاول ان تبحث عن اي صوره لانجاز او نصر
تسوقها في الشارع الاسرائيلي بعد اكبر
عمليه لاخفاء امني واستخباراتي شهدته
اسرائيل منذ تاسيسها في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر وبالتالي هناك
كانت تصريحات قد نشرها مباشره احد اعضاء
الكنيست من حزب الليكود الحاكم داني دانون
باركه للاجهزه الامنيه والجيش والشباك
والمشد على هذه العمليه مباشره اصدر مكتب
نتنياهو توجيهات وتعليمات لكافه الوزراء
والنواب في الكنيست بعدم الادلاء باي
تصريحات او اجراء مقابلات صحفيه كي لا
ينسب لاسرائيل بانها تعلن مسؤوليتها بشكل
علمي وصريح عن هذه العمليه اللافت ايضا في
هذا الموضوع اليوم انه هناك كان تعمد ربما
عبر وسائل الاعلام الاسرائليه الحديث عن
ان اسرائيل لم تبلغ الولايات المتحده ب
بنيتها تنفيذ هذه العمليه مسبقا وانما فقط
لدى تنفيذ العمليه تم ابلاغ الاداره الا
الامريكيه
ربما في حال صدقت هذه المعلومه من الجانب
الاسرائيلي في حالات سابقه كانت تعلن
الامر ذاته لكن ليتضح لاحقا بانه كان هناك
تنسيق بين الجانب الاسرائيلي والاداره
الامريكيه لكن في حال بالفعل كانت هذه
المعلومه صحيحه فهذا قد يشير ايضا الى
خشيه الجانب الاسرائيلي من منع من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه لتنفيذ مثل هذه العمليه
لاغتيال العاروري على الاراضي اللبنانيه
الخلاف قد يكون بين الاداره الامريكيه
وبين القياده الاسرائيليه ليس على اغتيال
قاضه من الصف الاول في حماس او على تصفيه
حركه حماس كما حدد لاهداف الحرب الدائره
ضد غزه بين الولايات المتحده وبين اسرائيل
وانما ربما فقط اي بلا تنفذ مثل هذه
العمليات على الارض اللبنانيه في المرحله
الراهنه لا سما وان الكثير من وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه والاجنبيه ايضا كانت
قد اشارت في بدايه هذه الحرب بان الولايات
المتحده هي من منعت اسرائيل من شن ضربه
استباقيه على لبنان تحديدا موجهه ضد حزب
الله خوفا من ان تتدحرج الامور الى حرب
اقليميه في المنطقه تصر حينها الولايات
المتحده المتحده الى الدخول الى خط هذه
الحرب المركه سلمى